The libertarian movement has lost
its way over the past 60 years
as it shifted from Friedrich Hayek's
classical liberal corrective to
depression era central planning
to Murray Rothbard
to full-blown anarcho-capitalism
in which all taxation is theft
and all transfer payments are
immoral.
That's the argument in a provocative
new book called Burning Down
the House How Libertarian
Philosophy Was Corrupted by Delusion
and Greed by Andrew Koppelman.
Reason spoke with Koppelman, a law
professor at Northwestern
University, about why he believes
classical liberals have given ground
to anarchism and how that
fundamentally changes not just
the rhetoric, but the political
goals of the libertarian movement.
Andrew Koppelman, thanks for talking
to Reason.
Happy to be here.
All right. So here,
give me this.
You're you're a law professor at
Northwestern University, right?
You've taught various places and
things like that.
Let's start. What's.
What's the elevator pitch of Burning
Down the House?
The elevator pitch is that
American libertarianism has
a valid core.
The valid core is understanding
the value of free markets,
which is something that is not well
understood by everyone on
the left.
But libertarianism
has increasingly taken
the form of an extreme
anti statism,
which
its proponents believe
will actually advance human liberty.
If we cripple the capacities
of the American state, it's
not going to do that.
And a large part of what
the state does is it
protects us from predators
and from forces that
aren't anybody's fault, but that
you need the state to control,
such as COVID is a good
example.
And so
the interest in
crippling state capacity
has ended up being a coalition
of two different
groups of folks.
There are the folks who believe in
bad political philosophy.
That's really the audience for my
book. It's people who are attracted
to this philosophy and who I want
to persuade to.
To Bad political philosophy.
Bad Political philosophy, political
philosophy that is poorly
reasoned and
that will not lead to the
attractive results that it
advertises, will not lead
to an advance in human freedom
and politics.
The desire to
cripple state capacity attracts
a coalition of idealists
who believe in that stuff
and unscrupulous
businessmen. Most businessmen are
very scrupulous, but the
unscrupulous ones are drawn
to this because it enables them to
hurt people without being bothered
by the police and so.
Well, delusion and greed.
That's the delusion.
And that's the greed.
Okay.
And to kind of put
some names on this,
essentially the book is
about how libertarianism
used to be.
And I think your your,
you know, case here is pretty valid
in the mid-twentieth century or
in the second half of the 20th
century, libertarianism was
kind of dominated by the thought
of Friedrich Hayek and
Hayekian libertarianism was
clearly part of
a liberal political
philosophy, was on a range,
you know, and there were people to
the left and to the right.
But he believed in things like
a functioning government,
social welfare spending,
you know,
I mean, basically, he believed in
limited government, more limited
than people on the left, less
limited or, you know, and more
limited than people on the right in
different ways. And that that
over time gave way ultimately
to a libertarianism, which is
really characterized by the thought
of Murray Rothbard.
Well, yeah.
And as a species of
anarchism, I'd say it's a kind of
right wing anarcho capitalism.
Yep.
Okay.
Let's start with the the controlling
metaphor of the book
Burning Down the House, because you
start out and you come back to
a story from a few years ago.
What what is what are you
referencing in the title?
The story is an episode
in Obion County, Tennessee.
The county doesn't have its own fire
department, and so it contracted
with a nearby fire department.
Or more precisely, it made
arrangements for its individual
residents to contract with
that nearby fire department
for fire protection.
And there was
an aging man here,
Gene Cranick, had paid
the fee every year, but
he's getting old. He starts
forgetting things.
He forgets to make the payment one
year and a fire breaks
out at his house and they call the
fire department and they're told
that, sorry, you didn't pay.
You can't pay now.
It's too late.
There's nothing that we can do for
you. And the fire department ends
up coming and they stand there and
they watch his house burn down.
They're there in case the house
spreads to the houses of the
neighbors who did pay, because
that's what they understand their
functions be.
And this episode
generates a furious debate
in the press.
And one of the
points of agreement between
the left and the right is
that this is the true face of
libertarianism, that you
have writers on the left saying,
look, this shows just
how harsh and cruel
unregulated capitalism is
and why we need to get away from
capitalism and move toward a system
that values people and not profits.
And people on the right saying,
look, the fire department did the
right thing. We've got to get people
to take personal responsibility
for what they are doing.
And what I want to argue is
that libertarianism has shifted
over time.
It's in its original form
it did not do remarkable
things like help the fire department
stand by and watch somebody's house
burn down.